so let's say you're running for
president and you're already up for
felons voting
well then champ which ones the cute ones
vegans register Democrats the answer
sky's the limit does this mean that you
would support enfranchising people like
the Boston Marathon bomber a convicted
terrorist and murderer if somebody
commits a serious crime sexual assault
murder they're going to be punished but
I think the right to vote is inherent to
our democracy yes even for terrible
people who are in convicted in prison
like the Boston Marathon bomber on death
row people who are convicted of sexual
assault they should be able to vote I
think we should have that conversation a
great answer so just days after
terrorists murdered over 300 men women
and children the Democrats tackle stuff
that truly matters
can our terrorists here still vote talk
about damning your own party of course
there are people who have lost their
voting rights forever Krystle Campbell
Martin Richard Lu lingzi and Sean
Collier can't vote the Boston bombers
suppress theirs permanently these
candidates also missed the point of
incarceration now if you're just joining
us from CNN this may shock you but when
you're in prison you lose rights it's
called prison not Spring Break so no
it's not a slippery slope when denying
voting rights because the slope doesn't
actually exist you're in jail there is
no freedom
you can't even vote with your feet but
in a socialist mind sense doesn't apply
socialists disguise their thirst for
power as the greater good which means
pretending to care while taking control
so it's not about helping those in jail
just expanding the jail to include you
and me Cuba Venezuela North Korea the
USSR would made them all so unique
every citizen was a prisoner in every
socialist politician the jailer which is
why this socialism thing really only
works for Bernie the rest of us serve
the sentence all right Juan here is my
therapy my theory almost a therapy
as asking you this question you know
that's the thing you should come to me
let's pretend okay so dr. dr. Williams I
have this problem I keep thinking that
Bernie Watts felons to vote because he
knows they'll vote Democrat is that
right yes that's right well that's what
Republicans think yes exactly although
the study show what that Republicans are
not going to benefit from felons voting
oh is that right yeah
oh I I didn't know that but I seems to
me that Republicans in Florida recently
in fact voted to allow felons once they
leave prison this is prison no but
remember what you heard from Kamala
Harris was I she's okay with once they
leave prison I think we need gotta make
that you Bernie I agree but Bernie did
is saying in prison yes so this wittily
was one this was like the kill shot that
they gave Dukakis remember Bernard Shaw
yes your wife rape your wife question
but that look it up was that the murder
that was a death sentence yeah if
somebody written explain if somebody
rapes and murders your wife would you
still be against the death penalty and
Dukakis said yes said yes and but here's
the reason why because it seemed like so
inauthentic I mean anybody who would do
damage to you my friends my family I
obviously emotion I want to go choke
that son of a gun right yes and so it
looked like the caucus was just plain
old but I think Bernie's being sincere
and I'll tell you why I think that if
you look at people who have been in
prison there is a nationwide sentiment I
think this crosses political parties
that says those people have to be
re-entry into society one of those
people well okay so it Bernie says well
if you're talking about housing if
you're talking about jobs if you're
talking about welfare you say hey that
guy committed a felony he can't reenter
society than what you're talking about
is that's gonna be a high level of
people once they get going back to crime
you are a terrible therapist it's like I
can't you with a with a problem and you
solved it you're going let's talk about
this other problem
what do you what do you make of this
because let's not let's keep it separate
what's-his-face what's this name again
Burnie yeah is talking about people who
are in jail terrorists
Democrats want terrorists to vote yeah
think about that one Greg yes they just
handed Donald Trump the wedge east of
wedge issues they could possibly do one
I have a question are Democrats trying
to lose this election no this is made to
order for Donald Trump I don't even
understand it this is Willie Horton 2.0
and Wow you think Willie Horton is good
men listen this is this is this is like
this is what it's like they've totally
undercut their whole messaging on
election integrity they've been saying
the Russians have been trying to hack
the democracy then they want to set up
voting booths on death row and I wonder
if there's ever going to be any
corruption or fraud with the voting
process in prison when you have guards
with batons looking down on guys filling
out their ballots it is the most
ridiculous thing I've ever seen and the
reason they're doing this one is because
they can't persuade enough actual voters
about their ideas so they have to create
new voters and they got rocked in 2016
so instead of trying to change their
message they're just trying to change
the rules this is what they did with
this Supreme Court expansion home this
is the electoral college all over again
do you think pedophiles voting or serial
rapists voting is going to play in Ohio
you know it's not my say Democrats are
trying to take away your First Amendment
rights or second Amendment rights but
they want to give voting rights to
terrorists are you okay got more votes
than the Republicans in 2016 I'm just
telling you all of them were felling or
at least living in California
same thing I'm from California Emily you
claim to be a lawyer yes what are your
thoughts on this
I I feel so strongly about this
let's keep it for the moment to the
presently incarcerated you make great
points and definitely yes that affects
six million people a year basically that
our post-conviction felons but I why I
think I think it raises a lot of great
questions why do we condemn our
incarcerated to civic death why when the
Supreme Court has recently affirmed
every other constitutional right why do
we take away their right to vote why do
we support in essence a prison based
gerrymandering when these the people
incarcerated are counted and not
legislative district in which they are
so that's not what Bernie's talking
about Bernie stop this Bernie is talking
about letting a terrorist vote while
he's in jail he's a citizen still sure
that I'm clear for viewers that um that
you can absolutely distinguish violent
crime convicts and obviously I think
when you reduce it to that tiny little
percentage of the serial rapists and
that bombers of course absolutely not
but I think it's right to acknowledge
the 2.3 million presently incarcerated
and to acknowledge that for everyone's
now kind of a bipartisan commitment to
criminal justice reform who better to
participate potentially than those
presently incarcerated and certainly you
can make the argument is this a 3/5
constitutional clause all over again
with that you know taxation without
representation in question but mayor
Pete Budaj
had a different answer and his instinct
was something that I would not think
most of them chickens would agree with
would you like to hear that please
let's lay that tape for Dana but just
for Dana part of the punishment when you
were when you were convicted of a crime
and you're incarcerated is you lose
certain rights you lose your freedom and
I think during that period it does not
make sense to have an exception for the
right to vote when people leave the
prison system they need to be
reintegrated into their communities they
need to be able to have a chance to get
a job to be able to find decent housing
and they need to be able to participate
in the political process
that means they made the right to vote
to be reinstated sorry about that
so Elizabeth Warren again is trying to
solve a different problem and that is
that after you have served your debt to
society we get if we believe that voting
is a privilege and it's a privilege of
your citizenship that there has to be
some sort of punishment for committing a
crime and in Florida there were a lot of
Republicans that voted for restoring
voting rights to felons they may see a
couple of exceptions for violent crime
and sexual assault but that is totally
different from people being able to vote
in prison and I think mayor Pete had a
much better answer than Bernie last
night yeah I think that's why mayor Pete
is rising because he's not crazy
do you Emily I feel like that asks the
question do you guys feel like voting is
a privilege or do you feel like it's
it's a right you can't hurt you if
you're a terrorist and you bombed my
take in there that right or privilege
take it away in a box and we think they
really care about voting they are in
print I mean they're already can't leave
so I don't see that we're arguing over
something so stupid I spend so much - I
spent a lot of time with inmates and
they they do care and I think that's why
I think although studies have shown they
might trend towards the Democratic Party
I do feel like a lot of them based on
their experience are wholeheartedly for
limited government and limited to
overreach because they're the ones a lot
of the time that are receiving the brunt
of it frankly well now you've changed my
mind all right you changed my mind you
came to me for therapy and I'm crazy now
yes